So let's see if we understood how
test and atomic-op logs work.
Remember our original code for
load links for
conditional locks which loads
the previous state of the lock,
tries to put one into the lock and
then checks whether we
observe the unlock state of the lock and
whether we successfully grab the lock.
So if we apply the test
an automatic approach to this.
Amazingly we do that by just
rearranging these instructions.
The first two instructions
are exactly the same.
And then in what order do we use
the remaining three instructions?
Instead of writing out the instruction,
just say which of these is
instruction A, B, and C.